it's thick it's plus size it's beautiful
it's fatty baddies ADI bodies loving
yourself no matter what you know and
it's also going through stuff you need
thick skin you have to learn and grow
and evolve from your experiences don't
let it break or shake you just learn
from it like I have been doing stand-up
comedy for a long time I'm very funny if
you can't tell and I always learn from
the bad shows more than the good shows
really and I think people want to feel
safe and their ego wants to be stroked
all the time but you got to get messy
you got to be comfortable with rejection
and figure out who you are in that
moment and so that's what the show is